[Música]
de función bienvenidas a la entrevista
de france 24 y radio france
internacional
hoy nos asociamos para una entrevista
excepcional ya que recibimos a svetlana
tica no pesca ya conocida opositora
bielorrusa de la que se hablan con
frecuencia a causa de las locuras del
dictador lukashenko
actualmente svetlana está en francia y
tienen la gentileza de contestar a
nuestras preguntas se tratará de saber
cómo piensa llevar a cabo la lucha hasta
la victoria hasta el poder en belarús y
también de saber qué tipo de régimen qué
tipo de democracia piensa instaurar
junto con otros opositores vio los rusos
que están refugiados algunos en polonia
otros en lituania o en otros países le
doy la palabra a denis strelkov mi
colega de la redacción rusa de radio
france internationale
gracias guti y gracias a usted por
concedernos esta entrevista vino a parís
para reunirse con el señor gianni letta
con otros responsables políticos
franceses cuál fue el tono de su
conversación central
hola hola a todos
todos los encuentros en francia han
ocurrido en un ambiente muy amable y
veamos que realmente quieren ayudarnos
pero a veces no se reúnen todas las
condiciones para hacerlo
pero vemos que todas las instituciones
todos los actores trabajan por
establecer una comunicación en
particular con los regímenes de los
dictadores
regímenes autoritarios
todo el mundo está tratando de entender
cómo se puede seguir ayudando a la
sociedad civil bielorrusa
cómo se puede presionar al régimen para
que el régimen entienda que no hay más
salida aparte de una negociación con la
población o una nueva elección
ustedes le prometieron algo y a ustedes
se les prometió algo
en cuanto a las promesas no yo no he
hecho ninguna promesa además de decir
que continuaremos con nuestra lucha el
tiempo que sea necesario
recibimos certezas es necesario seguir
buscando todos los medios para presionar
al régimen así que no eran realmente
promesas sino certezas
sí
justamente sobre las promesas o más bien
sobre las declaraciones
bienintencionadas que el poder francés o
que el poder europeo puede aportarle
tiene usted la impresión de que están
listos para ir más allá de esas
declaraciones amables dicho de otro modo
usted sabe que en europa a una cierta
cantidad de dirigentes tienen mucho
cuidado con belarús y también sobre todo
con la rusia de vladimir putin no está
decepcionada por algunas de estas
declaraciones de dirigentes europeos que
ciertamente tienen muy buena intención
pero que tal vez no irán más allá de eso
en primer lugar no creo que debamos
hablar aquí de la actitud de distintos
líderes frente a la federación rusa y
aquí estamos hablando de belarús
[Música]
y entiendo que haya una cierta
desconfianza frente a las acciones que
se están tomando a causa del hecho de
que lukashenko obtuviera el apoyo del
kremlin
pero lo que nosotros estamos explicando
es que desde hace 27 años todo el mundo
se acostumbró los europeos se
acostumbraron a ver a belarús bajo la
influencia de rusia pero es una sola
persona la que está bajo la influencia
del kremlin y por supuesto los pie los
rusos tienen muy buenas relaciones con
rusia no quieren romperlas pero quieren
escoger el destino de su país y eso no
disminuirá o perjudicará la cooperación
con rusia no hay que mezclarlo todo
abstraigan se de rusia piensan en
belarús estamos haciendo presión sobre
el régimen y no sobre nuestras
relaciones con rusia
por supuesto tal vez hay una cierta
desconfianza pero es necesario hacerle
entender y explicarle enviarle mensajes
correctos a rusia los pie los rusos no
están mirando hacia occidente no quieren
entrar a la unión europea oa la otan
como lo que dice la propaganda que
estamos vendiendo al país a occidente no
no se trata de eso
no se trata de geopolítica se trata del
factor humano
y del hecho de que nosotros mismos
queremos construir el futuro de nuestro
país
y
usted se reunió con él manuel ma como
hace un año esta vez fue con el jean
yves le drían les está pidiendo que
hagan presión sobre el régimen de
lukashenko o que más bien hablen con
vladimir putin para hacer presión sobre
el dictador bielorruso
con una muy por supuesto
con imágenes y señas
nosotros entendemos la importancia de
los intercambios con el kremlin y no
podemos hacerlo nosotros mismos sino
sólo a través de mediadores
así que es absolutamente necesario tener
una mediación
le pedimos a francia que juegue el papel
de líder en este tipo de intercambios y
en la organización de la mediación
introducía por supuesto juega un papel
muy importante en las relaciones con
belarús y también puede jugar ese rol de
mediador
entonces se trata de un diálogo entre
tres países
porque un diálogo entre tres países
alrededor de esa mesa de negociación es
posible tener otros países para que ese
diálogo sea abierto por ejemplo polonia
o lituania los intereses de esos países
están en juego al igual que el régimen o
sus amigos
luego del west punto con el que que
pulmón en europa occidental al encontrar
a alguien que se opone a una dictadura
oa un régimen autoritario se tiende a
glorificarlo
a adorarlo inmediatamente a veces hay
decepciones que puede usted decir y
garantizar hoy para que si algún día
llega al poder en belarús se trate de un
régimen auténticamente democrático
usted me dijo hace un rato que no quería
hablar de política sino de dignidad
humana es cierto que es importante
pero cuál es su idea para que ve la luz
sea un régimen democrático y hay un país
en el mundo en europa que le parezca ser
digno de inspiración
no estuvo
y el estratega sabe si hablamos de una
estrategia ideal sería tomar lo mejor
que hay en distintos países para luego
implementarlo en el propio país
y
usted me pregunta si puedo dar garantías
pero ya tuvimos una persona que dio
garantías durante 27 años
asegurando la estabilidad pero en
realidad nadie puede garantizar nada los
pie los rusos tienen el derecho a
decidir el destino y el futuro de su
país
ellos escogieron a la persona que
quieren que sea presidente después de
las elecciones
así que deben participar en la toma de
decisiones y si participan se trata de
una responsabilidad colectiva
todo el mundo desempeña su papel
nosotros los viejos rusos no tenemos
experiencia democrática o quizás sólo
dos años después del 91 se necesita
tiempo para aprender
así que imaginen una persona que
súbitamente debe cargar con la
responsabilidad de la toma de decisiones
hay que darles tiempo a estas personas y
aprenderán ya pagamos un precio muy alto
y pienso que los vilos rusos aprenderán
muy rápido esta versión nuestra
si se crean buenas condiciones de
trabajo si sienten que son respetados en
sus lugares de trabajo no como ahora
estarán motivados
harán mejor su trabajo servirán mejor a
su país
no como ahora con miedo a perder su
trabajo
a nosotros nos gustaría ver a nuestro
país desarrollarse y para esto
necesitamos una nueva elección libre y
equitativa
tal vez otra persona sea elegida
no sé quién participará en esta nueva
elección anticipada
nuestra tarea es garantizar una nueva
elección libre y equitativa y después
serán los vio los rusos quienes cargarán
con la responsabilidad del destino de su
país
svetlana hace un año yo la entreviste en
esa época todo el mundo estaba esperando
que la situación cambiará rápidamente al
final no fue así
todos podemos estar de acuerdo en eso
diría usted que esa fue una oportunidad
perdida para cambiar las cosas en su
país
gotas de metros donde vivir y los
tumores motion
hace un año nosotros también pensábamos
que podíamos cambiar la situación
rápidamente
creíamos que no era posible ignorar a
cientos de miles de personas que habían
salido a las calles
pero subestimamos la brutalidad del
régimen fue nuestro error sin duda
porque hacía 27 años que veíamos esa
brutalidad y estábamos tan acostumbrados
que ya no lo anotábamos
para ya venimos casos
y pensábamos que el régimen demostraría
ser comprensivo
pero vimos lo que pasó brutalidad
torturas violencia a causa de todo eso
pero no porque se normalizará la
situación las personas regresaron a sus
casas y algunos fueron encarcelados
algunos recibieron condenas y nos
gustaría que esas condenas se queden en
el papel
que no cumplan esas condenas en la
cárcel
la situación se deterioró para las
personas a causa de esa violencia a
causa del miedo pero también hay que
decir que fue mala para el régimen aquí
están las siglas trabaja no nada tarde
ocurre de destino
sólo nos quedan 30 segundos tiene usted
previsto tomar medidas concretas y
serias en los próximos meses aparte de
las sanciones económicas
y acciones serias las sanciones ya son
acciones serias la resistencia de los
vilos rusos es muy seria el movimiento
obrero el plan para moda de los antiguos
miembros de las fuerzas de seguridad no
subestima nuestras acciones nuestro
trabajo es mantenernos coherentes en el
interior del país y los actores
internacionales deben mantenerse
coherentes en sus propias políticas
así muchas gracias quédense con nosotros
en france 24 y rf